salut alors aujourd'hui pas de fond vert
pas de décor pas de blouse on va se
faire une vidéo comme ça entre nous un
petit peu plus intime calmez-vous il y a
quelques temps je vous avez demandé sur
insta de me poser vos questions santé et
ben aujourd'hui je vais y répondre
évidemment j'ai pris plusieurs questions
hein et j'ai pris des questions qui sont
susceptible d'intéresser un maximum de
monde allez
[Musique]
go alors vous allez voir il y a pas
vraiment d'ordre j'ai pas fait par
thématique j'ai juste enchaîné les
questions les unes après les autres
comme ça elles ont pas de rapport les
unes avec les autres et vous allez voir
soyez pas surpris est-ce qu'il y a des
traitements contre la déréalisation la
déréalisation j'ai prévu de faire une
vidéo là-dessus mais c'est vrai que pour
l'instant on en a jamais parlé donc vite
fait pour les gens qui connaissent pas
du tout la déréalisation comme la
dépersonnalisation qui ressemble
beaucoup c'est ce qu'on appelle des
troubles dissociatifs la dissociation
c'est quand on met une espèce de
distance entre nous-même et ce qu'on vit
ce qu'on ressent et cetera souvent c'est
pour se protéger de ses propres émotions
après un traumatisme par exemple et là
en l'occurrence c'est un petit peu comme
si on était détaché de ce qu'on vit et
de ce qui nous entoure comme si on
vivait dans une espèce de rêve mais pas
un rêve agréable comme si on regardait
tout ce qui nous arrive de l'extérieur
un peu comme si on était devant un film
sauf que c'est notre propre vie alors
dit comme ça c'est flippant mais déjà
c'est pas rare du tout et puis la
plupart du temps c'est pas grave du tout
non plus dans la mesure où oui ça se
soigne justement il y a des traitements
alors des médicaments pas vraiment sauf
ceux pour soigner ce qui peut déclencher
la déréalisation genre l'anxiété la
dépression et cetera mais il y a un
traitement qui existe et qui marche très
bien c'est la psychothérapie donc si tu
fais de la déréalisation hésite pas à
aller voir un psite est-ce que c'est
normal la symétrie de la poitrine bon
j'imagine qu'on parle des seins pas des
pecs et ben très clairement oui c'est
normal enfin je sais pas ce que tu
entends par normal mais en tout cas
c'est très très très répondu avoir un
sein plus gros que l'autre c'est vrai
chez la majorité des gens si on veut
être un peu tatillon je pense même qu'on
peut dire que personne n'a une poitrine
parfaitement symétrique juste des fois
la différence elle est tellement minime
que ça se voit pas à l'œil nu mais elle
existe quand même par contre oui des
fois ça se voit et quand je parle de
différence bah ça peut être la taille
mais ça peut aussi être la forme le
mamelon et cetera et cetera donc c'est
normal mais si ça te travaille il y a
deux questions à se poser la première
c'est est-ce que ça me dérange vraiment
au quel cas c'est bien d'aller en parler
avec quelqu'un et si au bout du compte
ça continue à être gênant bah c'est
possible de se faire opérer c'est pas
obligé mais c'est possible et l'autre
question c'est est-ce que ça a toujours
été comme ça ou est-ce que c'est apparu
un peu d'un coup et là si c'est oui il
faut aller chez le médecin pour
comprendre pourquoi pourquoi le sérumen
dans les oreilles bonne question en fait
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'à la base
le sérumen on l'avait au coin de la
bouche mais comme ça faisait vraiment
moche on a fini par nous le cacher dans
les oreilles non en fait le sérumen
c'est un peu l'agent de sescu de nos
oreilles le vigile si vous voulez déjà
quand il y a des trucs qu'on a pas du
tout envie de voir à l'intérieur de nos
oreilles qui arrivent à rentrer quand
même genre des poussières des moucherons
et cetera et ben le cumen il arrive et
il les attrape avec ses petits bras
gluants et si c'est des microbes c'est
exactement la même chose sauf qu'en plus
il contient des trucs qui arrivent à les
tuer et puis dernier truc dans notre
conduit auditif on a des petites peaux
mortes qui se détachent et ben là c'est
pareil le serumen il attrape tout ça et
ça finit par ressortir à l'extérieur
grâce au mouvement de nos mâchoires donc
le sérumen à l'intérieur il faut pas le
retirer faut juste nettoyer ce qui sort
à l'extérieur ça on en reparlera un de
ces jours j'ai eu se angines depuis
décembre dernier comment guérir ah oui
se quand même alors une angine déjà pour
que tout le monde soit d'accord c'est
une infection des amidales j'ai les
grosses boules qu'on a au fond de la
gorge quand as une angine pour guérir il
y a deux options soit c'est un virus et
là bah tu attends que ça passe en
mangeant des glaces et en buvant
beaucoup d'eau ça c'est le cas le plus
fréquent soit c'est une bactérie et là
ton médecin peut éventuellement te
prescrire des antibiot faut faire gaffe
avec les antibiots on en reparlera une
autre fois mais si on a les amidales un
peu sensibles un peu fragiles on peut
faire des angines à répétition c'est pas
méchant en soi mais à force ça peut
finir par être pénible c'est pour ça que
même chez les adultes oui même chez les
adultes on peut finir par retirer les
amidales c'est pas une grosse opération
en soi mais faut quand même que ce soit
justifié donc faut en discuter avec son
médecin mais bon là clairement C angine
en moins d'un an ça peut valoir le coup
on peut rien faire pour arrêter de
vieillir comme Mick Jagger ou Kiss
Richard alors déjà peut-être que que ça
fait longtemps que tu n'as pas vu Mick
Jager et Kiss Richard est-ce qu'on peut
vraiment dire qu'ils ont arrêté de
vieillir je dirais non mais ils ont 80
ans voilà donc ils sont vieux c'est
comme ça et c'est déjà pas mal qu'il
soit arrivé jusque là vu qu'ils se sont
collé toute leur vie mais pour répondre
à ta question est-ce qu'on peut arrêter
de vieillir bah non on peut rien faire
on peut vieillir très lentement si on a
le syndrome d'ylander mais je le
conseilleraai pas après est-ce qu'on
peut bien vieillir oui il y a plein de
trucs qu'on peut faire pour mieux
vieillir genre manger équilibré avoir
une activité physique régulière regarder
mes vidéos mais et en plus de tout ce
que tu peux faire pour vieillir le mieux
possible physiquement si tu veux deux
conseils voilà ce que je te dirais un
accepte que tu vieillis toute l'énergie
que tu vas dépenser pour faire croire
que non c'est de l'énergie perdue pour
faire des trucs cool et deuxième conseil
bah fais des trucs cool justement tu
peux rien faire pour pas vieillir tu
peux pas forcément éviter les maladies
les accidents et cetera mais tant que tu
peux faire des trucs cool dans ta vie
bah faisles est-ce qu'on peut tuer
quelqu'un en lui soufflant dans le P is
bon là j'imagine que tu fais référence à
la vidéo dans laquelle j'explique que un
vagin n'est pas un instrument avant on
ne souffle pas dedans donc on a vu que
c'est dangereux de souffler dans un
vagin mais dans un
pénis dans le cas du vagin ce qui est
dangereux c'est de souffler beaucoup
d'air d'un coup parce que ça peut se
retrouver soit dans le ventre la plupart
du temps soit carrément dans la
circulation sanguine en cas de grossesse
mais si on souffle dans un pénis il y a
pas ces risques là déjà parce que là on
souffle dans l'urêtre c'est le trou du
pipi et l'urêtre il est pas relié au
ventre il est relié à la Vess et puis
surtout parce que l'urettre c'est un
tout petit tuyau il est trop étroit et
en plus il est trop long pour qu'on
puisse envoyer plein d'air d'un coup
donc je dirais a priori pas de danger
mais je vais pas vous mentir j'ai pas
trouvé d'études scientifiqu FiBL hein
donc dans le doute ne faites pas ça si
vraiment vous aimez souffler dans des
trucs achetez-vous une
flute voilà DTC c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui j'espère que ce nouveau
format ça vous a plu si c'est le cas ou
si c'est pas le cas d'ailleurs
dites-le-moi dans les commentaires
hhésitez pas à vous abonner aussi à mes
réseaux sociaux parce que ce genre de
format bah j'en ferai aussi là-bas et
puis aussi plein d'autres trucs que je
ferai pas forcément ici et pour le reste
bah vous connaissez maintenant on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin des autres mettez-vous bien
et surtout portez-vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien